[Musique]
je me sens bien moi c'est sûr que c'est
lorsque je me sens le plus à l'aise
quand tu apprends à être heureux dans
toutes les conditions climatiques des
eaux
tu viens vraiment à être confortable
donc les conditions puis qu'est-ce que
tu es en p2c façon-là souhaite aussi peu
plus un peu à l'intérieur
[Musique]
on est pris toujours redonne de voitures
dans les bâtiments et tous et c'est là
qu'on parle de connexion
[Musique]
la façon la plus facile à se connecter
avec les montagnes de cette façon c'est
de monter sur le sommet des montagnes
parce que le tu vois un ancien de
montagne nattawut puis c'est vraiment là
que titre sans peur enfermés comme qui
en a des gens qui se ressent quand qui
vit dans les montagnes
[Musique]
on
la fois la plus rapide que je pense que
j'ai fait c'est une heure juste en bout
d'une heure et demie en partant d'en bas
c'est par 500 mètres
et puis tout le monde jusqu'à jusqu'à
près de 2000 justement de mire c'est un
sport qui s'est tellement beau sport
mais c'est pas pour tout le monde parce
que c'est difficile j'ai tombé en amour
avec le ski d'alpinisme le ski hors
piste
et puis c'est comme ça que moment donné
j'ai commencé à faire plus de bas que de
l'huile a maintenant j'ai presque de la
gêne de dire que j'ai plus de billets de
saison je fais seulement du ski hors
piste pour pour le ski tout l'hiver
l'arabica whistler j'ai eu une
opportunité incroyable de travailler
dans un bureau d'architectes m'ont
vraiment
prix 2 des bancs d'école et m'ont
apporté un niveau où je pouvais
pratiquer
pratiquer la profession et
c'est aussi au moment où j'ai commencé à
m'entraîner vraiment fort pour le ski
alpinisme pour la course de ski
alpinisme
c'était le temps des olympiques au juste
avant les olympiques il y avait
tellement d'énergie puis avait tellement
d'action plus oui c'est sur moi me
traînant pour le ski alpinisme ben
jannet oggi mougel et sur des pentes de
ski puis je voyais des gens qui
s'entraînait pour les vrais olympiques
puis c'est sûr que oui ça donne ça donne
envie puisse a dit ok est-ce que je suis
dans le bon sport où est ce que je fais
là bonne chose puis moi ma réponse pour
moi c'est toujours été riche comme
quelqu'un de vraiment passionné puis je
sais quand j'aime quelque chose je veux
vraiment jusqu'au bout
tu parles jamais un jour arrêter d'être
montagnards parce que pour moi c'est pas
nécessairement un style de vie ça fait
partie de moi c'est quelque chose que je
suis née comme ça je suis né et j'ai
grandi en forêt puis même on a parlé
avec mes parents ça jamais des
différents
j'ai tellement envie de transmettre
toutes ses passions leurs la montagne la
nature la vie en communauté
puis pour moi je sais que c'est comment
graver dans mon
dans mon système que c'est le style de
vie puis c'est comme ça que je veux
passer le reste de ma vie
[Musique]
nous la famille on est nous plaît de
parents on vient de france
et puis on a quatre enfants trois filles
et un garçon maintenant alors moi je
suis pas quelqu'un de très solitaire et
je peux pas rester seuls trop longtemps
donc non je sais je pense que oui il ya
eu du jeu des amis qui aiment mettre au
fin fond des bois loin et retrouver un
peu ce côté solitude mais on a cette
chance aussi ici qu'on n'est pas obligé
de vivre seul parce que comme je disais
la communauté quand même assez
secondaire
cette solidarité est ce qu'elle est
elle est liée à la montagne en tout cas
chez un voisin que ça puisse lier au
canada qu'à la montagne parce que nous
par exemple on vient de la montagne en
france et est pourtant dans des petits
villages aussi encore plus petits
j'avoue que je connaissais pas ce genre
de de solidarité
[Musique]
à